[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks, Dan.
That was awesome.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Nathan Camarillo.
I'm a senior product manager
on the living room team.
And today, I want to tell you
more about our technologies
and some of the great
improvements our team has
recently made to enable new
experiences in the living room.
Our first product
was the Chromecast.
And it was the top selling
streaming device, including
streaming boxes, in 2014.
That momentum
continued into 2015,
and we introduced a new Chrome
cast in Chromecast Audio.
The new Chromecast
has better Wi-Fi,
supporting both
2.4 and 5 gigahertz
Wi-Fi, a better physical design
for behind the TV connectivity,
and upgrades our
Chromecast app to service
all the great content, apps,
and games that you love.
We built a larger
ecosystem of devices
from televisions,
to set-top boxes,
like the Razer Forge
TV and NVIDIA Shield,
and audio devices powered
by Google Cast for audio.
All of these products continue
to see tremendous success.
We're always improving
the developer experience
by unlocking even more
opportunities to extend
your games to the living room.
And televisions with
Android TV already built
in, like the Sony Bravia,
are proving very successful
and give you all the power
of the Android TV platform
with Google Cast built in.
Simply put, Google is
already in the living room.
Come join us if you
haven't already.
We're here and we'll continue
to be here in the future.
So first, let's talk
about Google Cast.
Google Cast is designed to
use your mobile experiences
to drive entertainment
experiences on your home
devices.
People love using their
mobile devices and tablets
to find content quickly without
the cumbersome chore of setting
up all their accounts and
trying to find content
with a traditional
slow remote interface.
And Chromecast is really easy.
You just pick content using the
apps you already know and love,
you tap the Cast button, and you
enjoy the content on your TV.
A Google Cast game extends
this concept to gaming
and enables multi-screen game
playing between mobile devices
and television.
People love games--
so much so that it's
the most popular category by far
of all apps in the app stores,
but gaming on the TV is not
always that easy or cheap.
You need a device
that's a few hundred
dollars, like a console, or you
have to buy a remote or game
controllers for every player.
Wouldn't it be so
great if I can just
play any of the
mobile games I usually
play on my phone on the TV?
With Google Cast, you can.
It leverages the
power of your phone
to render great gameplay on
your TV which just a $35 device,
or you can cast it
to your Android TV.
And we made it easy
for any mobile game
to get on the TV
with Google Cast.
That's why we created the Remote
Display APIs for Google Cast.
There's millions
of mobile devices
with powerful GPUs and
sensors ready to send
amazing interactive content to
the largest screen in the home.
With the Remote Display
APIs for Google Cast,
this is now possible.
To make it extra simple, we
released a Unity remote display
plug-in in the fall.
There is a Unity plug-in
sample to get you started,
and you'll be
surprised how quickly
you can extend your existing
Unity game to the TV.
With all of our
technologies, you'll
find online tutorial videos,
all the documentation you need,
code labs, and more.
And if you enjoy developing
natively for Android,
there are lots of
endpoints out there
for you to reach
with Android TV.
Android TV is scaling
rapidly with more partners
across many regions.
That means more set-top
boxes, and more smart TVs
to run your great
gaming experiences.
Android TV can power everything
from high end experiences,
like Razer Forge TV and
NVIDIA Shield set-top boxes,
creating a AAA immersive
gaming experiences,
such as the upcoming
release of Borderlands:
The Prequel straight
from the console world
to profound opportunities to
do D-pad simple games with even
a larger reach cross
all end points.
As mentioned earlier, since
every Android TV is also
a Google Cast end point,
there are many ways
to extend the gaming
experience into living rooms
all around the world.
And what does this mean for
you as a game developer?
Across all of our technologies,
when games and apps
are connected to the TV, we
see increased engagement,
stronger monetization, and
because the living room is
inherently social,
multiplayer games that result
in more downloads for you.
Because you can utilize
the reach of these devices,
all the power of the
platform, like payments,
already exist for you.
The party is just
getting started.
And we're saving a
seat just for you.
The living room will continue
to be a very exciting place,
and we'll be there with you.
Thanks, everybody.
And allow me to introduce Cliff,
who is going to speak next.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]